[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000 as always my name is caleb
denby
and tonight i want to walk you through
some really really interesting games
going on in the 2020 chinese chess
championships
that's not chinese chess but that's
chess in china
and i guess as kova restrictions are
being a little bit lifted
in some of these countries uh in europe
and asia we are seeing these national
championships that got pushed off for
some time
all at once of course the russian
championship just finished up with your
new russian champion
jan napomnishi and we are well underway
in the chinese championship
as well uh you actually have a few
leaders
in the the championship as of recording
this wei yi
uh yu yang yi are the two wei yi and yu
yangi
are the two big names that you expect to
see at the top and they are tied to
first
but there is actually a third player
tied for first that i was
less familiar with and that is lu shang
lei
uh i i don't think he's a new name in
the
realm of chess in china but he is
certainly making an impression
in this championship uh so to start with
i actually wanted to show you a game
from one way ye at one point of course
for those of you don't know
wei yi was the child prodigy in
the realm of chess and everybody
expected him to go very very far with
his chess career
and he definitely has and he's showing
how he has sort of evolved as a player
in this game here so let's just jump
into it here we have wei yi
against a player by the name of zhu
xiangyu who has actually been playing
some really really interesting chess
uh in this championship unfortunately
for him
a lot of his interesting games have
ended up on the losing side he's had a
very up and down tournament some really
nice wins
and a couple you know really nice losses
if something
uh could be a nice loss but let's take a
look here weigh you plays d4
zhu shang yu plays knight f6 we get c4
g6 knight c3 and d5
entering the grunfeld and if there's one
thing you can say about the grunfeld
it's that it ends up in some really
really interesting and
rather unique pawn structures and that's
why i wanted to show you guys
uh show you guys this game we really
does
just a masterful job of understanding
how to work with an extremely fractured
pawn structure
and how to still maintain some kind of
advantage
throughout so let's take a look we have
d5 entering the grunfeld
and the idea of the grindfeld of course
is that after c takes d5
and knight takes d5 we have a lot of the
black pieces
ganging up on the dark squares in the
center and
on the queen side as well trying to make
this a powerful piece
but in exchange black has given up the
powerful d5 pawn
for the slightly less powerful c4 pawn
and this is going to allow white to
build a big center
with the move e4 and so that's what we
see here
zhu continues on now with knight takes
c3
b takes c3 and now c5
just normal grunfeld stuff so far now i
will say
generally they put the bishop on g7
first but it doesn't really matter so c5
now we get knight f3 which is sort of
the the quote unquote old main line
by wei now bishop g7 all according to
plan so far
as i said black gangs up on the dark
squares in the center and now white is
just aiming to finish development
and hold on to these dark squares for
the moment
and keeping in line with that strategy
we do see wei yi
continue out now with bishop e3
supporting the center
now the reason why bishop g4 is sort of
the old main line
is in many many cases you see black able
to play this move bishop g4
and help advance this dark squared plan
these days there are a few different
main lines that that white can try
but the one that i prefer actually
involves playing this move bishop c4
and dropping this knight into e2 so i
can preserve it with
the move f3 but here we see wei yi
willing to sacrifice some of this dark
squared control
in exchange for the bishop pair allowing
black
to take away this knight that controls
dark squares for this bishop which can
not
is a rather double-edged way to play and
now we see ye
uh take the game down even stranger
paths with the move queen to a4
check and this move may seem a little
bit strange
sort of inducing black to play in the
developing move of knight c6
now we would love to play d5 winning a
piece but you have to be careful of this
pawn on c3
so not really playable immediately is d5
because bishop takes c3 is just in fact
quite quite good for black this is not
going to be one of the good exchange
sacrifices in the grunfeld
so queen a4 check may seem strange just
sort of inducing black to develop pieces
with knight c6
but it actually comes with a pretty
instructive idea
so very often in these grunfeld openings
of course the battle
centers around the d4 pawn as i've been
talking about
so with queen a4 check weighty takes an
opportunity to put this queen on a nice
active square
where it still controls d4 and actually
vacates the d1 square
for a rook to potentially step in if
necessary
but even deeper than that i think the
main idea of queen a4 check
is to not allow the same idea by black
queen a5
is very often a good move for black in
these positions
activating the queen hitting another
dark square and
similarly clearing the d8 square for a
rook
to potentially jump into so quick a4
check i think yes it's a nice activating
move
allowing a rook to potentially come to
d1 but more than that it's actually a
preventative move
preventing moves like queen a5 from
coming too quickly
just a little bit of explanation there
for why queen a4 check
is the move now rook c1 is the follow-up
by wei yi
potentially you know even further
showing that rook d
won this idea of vacating the d file yes
it exists but it wasn't really the main
point
so what's the downside to queen a4 well
of course now black has the opportunity
to capture here on
f3 and fracture the pawn structure for
white and that's exactly what happens
here
okay so with uric c1 white is in fact
making a threat
this idea of bishop takes c3 is no
longer in the position
so d5 does need to be dealt with and
that's why we see e6 here
by xiu zhongyu and now the game
continues
with bishop b5 and black king's side
castles
and we see bishop takes c6 and
b takes c6 so
entering quite a unique pawn structure
as i said before
so let's see how uh wei yi
decides to handle this pawn structure in
order to try
to get an advantage because i have a
secret for you
zhu xiang yu has actually had this
position before this exact position
was actually played in the previous year
between front makumian
with the white pieces and again xu
xiangyu
with the black pieces so he had some
experience there
and zhu actually ended up losing that
game so perhaps he was looking
to be the first person to deviate and
play something better
so i want to get some ideas from the
chat here of how you would continue
with the white pieces i sort of
explained what happened in the opening
didn't ask for too much interaction
but this is your position now and how do
you want to
actually handle this position with white
it's it's pretty unique you have a
absolutely massive center both sides
though
have weaknesses in their structure and
you still have yet
to figure out what you're doing with the
king so let's see what the chat thinks
should be done
so a lot of people in the chat want to
play the move king e2
and that's a pretty reasonable move i'm
not going to tell you that that's a bad
move
because it's not a bad move king e2 is
definitely one way
to handle the position
and let's see what other ideas the chat
has before i go ahead and give you
a little bit more insight
i'm curious also what you guys are
actually you know thinking about what's
what's going through your head here
what's your reasoning
behind these moves
okay so a couple really great ideas
savage gamers
wants to take pawn taking a pawn not
always such a bad idea in this case
though there are some tactical issues
here uh
black is going to be able to play the
move rook c8 this queen will have to
leave
and then c takes d4 and you're just
simply unable
to hold on to everything here with
pressure down the c file
black is going to be winning back upon
quite comfortably
on d4 so queen takes c6 worth thinking
about
but not yet worth playing so ke2
it has been the choice for a lot of
people with the reasoning being
yes white has some weaknesses on both
sides
so why not keep the king in the center
and
this is a pretty interesting idea
but the reason why i don't think this is
quite correct
is because now you have weaknesses on
both sides and leaving your king
in the center of those weaknesses may
not be the best way
to uh to stay safe you're definitely
gonna have to be on your guard
for the rest of the game here with the
king on e2
so i actually like what wei yi uh did
the best here
and it was an idea mentioned in the chat
although i'm curious if the chat
actually had
the the exact same intentions uh as wei
yi here and that move is
h4 and now what is h4 well i don't
really think at its core h4 is is a
super strong
attacking move i don't think that's the
idea here
h4 is actually an attempt to shore up
some of these weaknesses
on the king's side now how does that
make any sense well
compare this with the move king e2 or
with king's side castles
against either of these moves black is
going to be able to start invading
with moves like queen to h4 and moves
like rook b8
right just coming after this king here
similarly kingside castles queen
h4 and actually
worth noting this is exactly how the
game between malcumian
and zhu continued malcumian castled
king's side and
zhu uh played the move queen out to h4
and got some king's side pressure now
malcolm
actually did go on to win that game but
this is i believe
you know approximately level here black
has good play
on the king's side and like i said
similar problems exist if you just play
the move king a2
so yes h4 is a good attacking move
threatening things like
h5 and black would do well to actually
respond to this threat
as zhu does in the game playing h5
but now the main point is that black is
not so
ready to invade on the king's side here
and wei yi's plan
is actually now to further shore up at
the king's side
by bringing the king over here using the
king and the rook on
h1 yes sort of as attacking pieces
threatening
things like h5 but firstly as defensive
pieces sort of
building a makeshift castle here and
that's why i found this game so
interesting and that's why i wanted to
go over it
this idea of playing h4 and playing king
f1 king g2
is i i think pretty unique you don't see
this idea sort of
every day where you advance upon on the
king's side
in order to make the king's side safer
for your king
so i want to talk a little bit about
this how do you arrive at this idea of
h4 king f1 king g2 in the position
and that idea comes down to thinking
about weak squares this is an idea i've
been talking a lot about lately
but if you look at white's position what
squares have been weakened
by the pawn structure deficits well
we're missing a pawn on g2
so that weakens these squares it weakens
f4 and it weakens
h4 right these are the four main
weaknesses created
by moving this pawn from g2 to f3
because
on g2 the pawn is able to defend those
squares
and on g3 the pawn is able
to defend uh f4 and h4 as well
uh and similarly you can even argue that
h2
is going to be weakened by this deficit
because it no longer has the opportunity
to step to a square like h3
and be defended so all these squares
have been weakened
by white's pawn structure deficits so
what does way ye do
well he finds a way to help cover up
some of those squares
and he does so by playing h4 now
let's examine the squares that are
weakened
these are the squares we were talking
about beforehand
and now three of those are well covered
by the rook
and after we see kf1 to king g2 we see
wei yi even further covering these
weaknesses
so that is the the masterful opening
idea by
wei yi that that i wanted to share so
any questions on
on this idea because i think it's a
really really important one to uh to
think about
uh it's an idea that you can actually
try to apply
in your own games whenever you have a
pawn structure deficit
definitely think about the squares that
are weakened don't just think about the
weakened pawns themselves
because they're not always the most
relevant in this case the more relevant
factor
are these weak squares and that's why we
place h4 to defend them so questions on
this idea here
questions on this idea
exquisite corpse is adding on a couple
more ideas
which we'll talk about and all right
seems like most people
have have a good grasp here so exquisite
corpse in the chat was talking about
potentially covering the king
with bishop f4 to g3 and i actually
don't think this is necessary because
this bishop is really really important
on e3
supporting our dark squares and we'll
see
that's uh we actually has a different
idea in mind for helping to cover this
diagonal
as for covering the open quote-unquote
g-file in front of the king
that job is actually already being done
all of the squares in front of the king
are covered one way or another and so
there's actually not much danger
from the g file being open which is why
we see king f1
now the game continues with king h7
ants now with wei yi having solved the
problems on the king's side for the most
part
we do actually see him now playing for
an advantage elsewhere on the board
so like i said weighie well
uh in progress for defending the
weaknesses
in his pawn structure on the king's side
black on the other hand
definitely has problems to deal with on
the queen side
so wiggy says free pawn is free and
captures here on c5 notably still queen
takes
is is going to be met by by rook c8 and
all of the same problems that we talked
about
previously so d takes c5 wigi's move
gaining a pawn now we do see queen c7
defending c6
and threatening to invade somewhere on
this diagonal potentially
and now king to g2 is weighies
idea defending once again all of the
weaknesses
and now bishop to f6
and i will be very very impressed if
anybody can come up with the move
that's uh that way yeed shows in this
position uh i will be somewhat astounded
if you guys can tell me whe's next move
but i'll give you a shot
chat room what do you think wei yi chose
to play in this
position
so a lot of moves being suggested in the
chat
people seem to be thinking the move e5
is worth playing
i am not sure that i agree
i just don't see the point if queen
takes e5 then you have a point
but bishop takes c5 is just a pawn right
just just free pawn
bishop g5 is also being suggested bishop
d4
so f4 is being suggested and that 4 is
an important idea that we're going to
keep an
eye on here so what is the idea of a
move
like f4 well the idea is to start taking
over these dark squares
work on shutting this bishop out and
build a stronghold
on the d6 square and
who sees an idea forming on the d6
square who sees a potential idea
involving the d6 square before i tell
you
what way ye played here and by the way
nobody in the chat has said the move
that wei yi plays which is sort of what
i expected
this one is a little counter-intuitive
peter peterson says the king is safe on
e2
and in this case yes the the king would
be reasonably safe
on e2 but in this case the king is
actually more useful
on g2 it's not just about king safety in
this case it's about king usefulness
because after wiggy's next move which
chess king has finally said
rook h to d1 paradoxically undefending
the pawn on h4 we actually need the king
on g2 rather than e2 in order to cover
these weaknesses made
by the loss of our g pawn well not the
loss but the
you know movement of rg pawn to f3 we
need to guard these weak squares over
here
and you can compare this position to if
for example let's say king e2 here
i know this doesn't make much sense but
let's say this happened instead now all
of a sudden
queen h2 ideas are in the position with
bishop h4 to follow
and uh you've got some serious problems
here right you've got some serious
serious problems we would want our king
on g2
to stop ideas like queen to h2
so that is why the king is on g2 it
helps actually cover the weaknesses
not just about king safety but about
king usefulness as well even in the
middle game
and so yeah we we see rook h to d1 by
way ye and what is the point well the
point is
this pawn for the moment is untouchable
due to the threat
of the rook coming in to d6 for example
bishop h4 rook d6 makes an immediate
threat
and again a threat which is a lot more
potent because we have h2 covered
black can try to defend but now we're
going to bring a second rook into the d
file and rook d7 is is tough to stop
bishop f4 ideas are in the position as
well
and this is just a pleasant advantage
for white so
pawn on h4 not really touchable at the
moment which is why we see black just
sort of calmly defending the d6 square
with the rook
on d8 uh and now
we see a pretty interesting series of
moves now
if these this series of moves were
played in
uh sort of an amateur game uh even a
game of people
sort of at my level one would assume
that both sides
were sort of playing one move at a time
and sort of lucking into the next idea
but i suspect wiggy and xu xiangyu had a
little bit of a deeper understanding
than that than that but it is kind of
funny to see the next moves
so surface level our pawn on h4
is attacked so wei yi goes to defend it
right and then of course
let's pretend he's a patzer just misses
the fact that the pawn can be captured
anyways
right king h3 bishop takes h4 played in
the game
now of course king ticket stage 4 would
be a bit of a mistake
because now this h2 weakness has
actually come back to bite us
as we are in fact getting checkmated
here
one way or another checkmate is coming
for us
there you go checkmate i did it um
so um king h3 bishop takes h4 is a
pretty funny sequence
and then of course we being a passer lux
into the move
rook to d6 and uh and all as well
so what's actually going on here let's
let's talk about it a little bit
so uh what is what is going on here
what is going on here excellent
questions
uh basically king h3 is in fact a useful
move to defend the h4 pawn even if
it cannot recapture after the immediate
bishop takes h4
and that's because rook d6 is in fact a
good response to bishop takes h4
now why not rook d6 immediately if you
know this is such a good idea why not
play it right now
and the difference here is that after
rook takes on d6
there's not really any type of bishop f4
cleverness there's no
c takes d6 with a threat to the bishop
cleverness
and that's why we need the king on h3
and to divert this bishop out to h4
before we go
for this idea now black is simply
winning a pawn
so king h3 bishop takes h4 rook d6
and now if rick takes d6 of course
simplest is c takes d6
when this same idea is or sorry
when now we go e5 with with a clever
idea so our king takes h4
still not going to be good enough
because queen h2 while not checkmate in
that case with the missing rook
is still good enough for a draw
so sort of crazy stuff going on here a
little bit of a little bit of a black
and
back and forth bluff here with king h3
pretending to defend the pawn
but then bishop takes h4 potentially
just being a mistake anyways because
rick d6
is is so powerful uh all that being said
it's already kind of a tough position
for black here
white is in fact uh up a pawn and
if you sort of take your time here just
play some random move like king g8
or i don't know rook a to b8 for example
white is going to continue now with f4
and with this idea of
e5 and then we'll see uh weighty has a
deeper idea to follow as well
but let's stick with the game for the
moment this is basically just an
accelerated version of what wei yi would
have gotten anyways
with the the caveat that wei yi does
have to sacrifice the h4 pawn for the
position
so the natural move is bishop e7 and
then
as everybody expects we are willing to
sacrifice this rook with the move
e5 and that is the the character of the
game here
uh so a lot of decisions being made in
the past few moves
and like i said you know at the surface
it looks like both players are sort of
just winging it move by move like king
h3
whoops hung my h4 pawn guess i go rook
d6
and then black is like wait a second
this is this is too good and then plays
bishop e7 and white's like hold on
bishop e7
guess i'm sacrificing the exchange but
at the top level i'm sure both players
had a pretty good idea
of what was actually going on here just
funny to see
okay so c5 and e5 in the position
and now if black does not actually take
this rook
well you're going to be stuck defending
the c6 pawn for the rest of eternity
so black does decide that it is time to
snack on this rook this of course
fixes white structure and after queen c8
we have a a new position uh entirely to
think about
so why this rook d6 stuff why
why go for this rook d6 trying to to fix
the structure here
and the the answer is it's really the
only way
for white to try to play for an
advantage and this goes back to the move
rook
h to d1 if
white isn't doing this this kind of
thing then what what is
what does white do instead right you
just have to try to attack the
weaknesses
in black's camp somehow a7 is just very
very difficult
to to actually get at and that leaves c6
how do you attack
c6 well you got to play rook d6 and
that's just how weigh yi
arrives at this idea because there's
just
a lack of any other ideas i think
that being said i think a move like f4
here might have been a slightly tamer
way to go about things
but this does allow uh black sort of an
opportunity here to play the move e5
and try and free the position uh j just
a little bit
right freeze the position a little bit
you're no longer so
ready to play a move like f4 and black
is the first one
to really invade on these files
interesting game interesting game so
rook d1 king h3 take rook d6
bishop e7 and e5 by the way rook takes
c6
is perfectly playable here and is maybe
even better than the exchange sacrifice
but way you just decided against it
there are a couple of reasons perhaps
for this
one is that queen e5 may be a good
activating move here
just bringing the king in and going for
some kind of attack
and number two is queen d7 would for
some simplifications here
and perhaps black is going to be able to
regain some material
on the c file but just a pleasant
advantage for white
instead though we get the exchange stack
with e5 take on d6 take on d6
queen back to c8 and now the the power
of this sacrifice sort of comes to play
here
when we see the move queen f4 and
now white's seemingly airy king is
actually doing a fantastic job
of guarding all the weak squares on the
king side
and black's seemingly protected king is
actually the one under a little bit of
danger here
as white's remaining major pieces are
able to use the
the half open files so queen f4
invading with queen h6 and attacking d7
just
pleasant for white rook d7 is pretty
much the only move you have to defend
this guy somehow
but now we see queen h6 check king g8
and the rook swinging over
to g1 just continuing the attack
uh zhu zhongyu continues to activate now
with the move rook b8
when you do have the extra rooks it's
really important to activate them on the
open files
and now we see sort of a subtle move
by wei yi here in the form of king h2
and i'm not going to lie to you this one
is
a little bit over my head i would have
thought that the king is placed
perfectly you know well on h3 but
king h2 just sort of the the waiting
move that uh wiggy chooses
to uh to go for here uh and part of the
reason i think for this move is that it
is in fact a waiting move
uh trying to to sort of bait black into
weakening the position somehow
for example if you get a little bit
antsy and play a move
like rook b2 well now queen takes h5
may actually lead to to some advantage
here for uh
for white just because rook b2 isn't
doing anything
and now if you try to come over this way
there's some weaknesses in in the black
camp
on the back rank for example so king h2
pretty high level waiting move
i don't really fully get it but that's
okay um queen f8 played and now white
does snack on the h5 pawn which is what
i would have played immediately
and by the way this is perfectly fine
immediately as well
but king h2 first okay queen g7 queen
over to g5 now
and rook f8 and this is the idea
that perhaps starts leading uh black
down
the wrong path here so fearing some of
this danger
on the king side black goes for sort of
a weird change in structure trying to
undermine the d6 pawn with a move like
f6 but this idea just turns out to not
work out
very well for zhu
so i think a better plan would have been
to activate the rook somewhere
along this file something like rook b5
looks pretty tempting
with a threat to the e pawn and actually
a threat to the d-pawn as well
and in fact potentially white just
doesn't have a good solution to this and
it is going to lose
uh going to lose one of these pawns for
example f4 rook takes d6
and the game is a lot closer to equality
uh instead though we see rook f8 and now
white does just have a nice advantage
bishop d4 is the continuation chosen by
wei
yi and the idea here is to simply cut
out black's
potential idea of f6 by uh defending
that square
you know pretty simple stuff so black
now has to go for c5 to divert the
bishop before playing f6
and now by the way if queen takes on g6
this is perfectly fine
for white but it's not really anything
more than fine
because at the end of the day three f
pawns is not going to be easy to win
with
and you immediately lose one of them so
instead
of queen takes g6 we see queen g4 by
white
keeping pieces on the board threatening
the e6 pawn
king f7 is black's choice here trying
desperately to hold everything together
sort of a similar idea to what we saw
from wei yi earlier in the game
but this time it's just not quite as
effective we continues with queen a4
hitting the rook on d7 now rook b7
uh you know saves the rook but the the
blockade of this d-pawn
is sort of failing a little bit king g2
now
uh brings the king off the h file
we see f takes c5 bishop back to e3
and the plan now is is rather simple for
weighty uh way he's just going to
balance threats to the king's side
keeping his own king safe
and in the long term c4 c5 c6
is just going to be the the winning idea
the game continues with king back to g8
now queen back to g4
hits these pawns again rook b to f7
but uh now the pawn does rush we get
rick takes f3
queen takes c6 queen f7 check
and the trade of queens and these pawns
are simply too strong
rook d7 rook d1 c6 is a threat
rook c8 and from here on out it's it's
just a winning end game
for wei yi although we do see sort of a
lot of
shuffling back and forth first things
first activate the king
and that's what we does and then
black activates the king as well but now
loses sight of the e5 pawn
which does fall white activates the king
and now we start our big shuffle fest
shuffle shuffle shuffle shuffle shuffle
shuffle
by the way i should mention uh black is
never really able to capture on this
pawn because of rick e7 and black is
never really able to capture
this pawn because of c6 and so that's
why you see white sort of
just randomly hanging pawns all over the
place they can't really be captured
so we shuffle for a bit and then
eventually
gives up and trades off one of the rooks
and
from here i dare anybody to find out
how to make progress all right there is
an absolutely insane plan that wei yi
found in order to to win this game
so take a moment think about it in the
chat think about what black's defensive
plan
is and then think about how you can stop
this defensive blockade
and i know i went really fast through
the past like you know
15 20 endgame moves but that's because
the evaluation was
was never really changing there both
sides were just
activating there were no really big
changes in structure or anything just
getting the pieces into the game
and shuffling so here we are though
critical moments
critical moments
ah and the chat is fighting amongst
themselves disaster
disaster nobody knows what's going on
okay there are some ideas in the chat
though
uh bishop b1 to h4 to e7
to h4 okay i don't know why that was
necessary
back to f2 and then king e5
and f5
okay maybe this plan is good
maybe this plan is good what could be
the problem with this plan
ah i see the problem with this plan
whenever you play king e5
i will play rook to f8
you're no longer threatening c6 if you
move your king off of d5
okay who else has a plan king d4 king e3
king f3 king g4 king g3 king h4
so again the problem is if you move this
king from d5 you're no longer
threatening to play c6
so black can move the rook in order to
help defend
the pawns uh chess king is close
chess clean king is close a5 a6 bishop
a5 bishop b6
and that may be good enough actually
but uh i lied no it's not a5
rook c6 and it it can be rather
difficult to to play a6 in time
right can be rather difficult for
example you may never do it
right black is allowed to shuffle like
this as well as like this
but chess king is close chess king is on
the trail
bishop a4 to c7 followed by c6 so this
is a good idea as well
this is a good idea as well but again
but again
rook a6 to c6 is an allowable pass as
well
but you guys are getting the right idea
here you guys are getting the right idea
you have to
interfere with this rick somehow
c6 zac the pawn absolutely not what's
wrong with you what's wrong with you
what's wrong with you no no no no no so
uh chess king is so close he might as
well be right but
still not quite right the key is to play
bishop e6
with the pawn on a5 you can't ever
really get this pawn to a6
because the rook is going to be
shuffling back and forth here when we
put our bishop on c7
but we can put the pawn on a5 and that
is good enough
to play the key move bishop b6 so here
we see wei yi play bishop a5 black
passes with rook c6
bishop c7 rook a6 but now
a5 rook c6 and bishop b6
is the killer killer move here
putting the bishop where it's hanging
but preventing black
from passing with the move rook a6 and
this
is going to be the winning idea four-way
yi
really impressive plan here just taking
away all of the rook squares
so now this pawn is forced to move to
the fateful square
of a6 and now bishop d8
is the final move of the game uh
bishop c5 i think is just as good but uh
bishop d8
is funnier so way ye picks the funny
move now for xc8
the idea is just bishop c7 of course and
c6
is unstoppable uh by the way if you do
take this bishop
you are met with an unfortunate case of
zugzwang here
uh you have to move the rook because if
you move the kink i'll take the rook
and then b7 is good enough the rook must
move
c6 c7 and queen
or c7 and queen
uh either way so bishop b6 and bishop d8
and here zhu zheng yu had had enough and
threw in the towel went ahead
and resigned really impressive idea
though bishop v8 idea doesn't work it
might but i think uh are you actually
making progress right are you making
progress here
i don't i don't think you are because i
have rook a6
and maybe you can do some funny like
tempi tempe thing
like you go bishop c7 or k6 here here
bishop here
maybe you can't do a funny tempi thing
but yeah bishop b6 key idea i don't
think you can make bishop b8 work
and the point is you deprive the rook of
the a6 square and now your idea of
bishop
c7 is a winner really great stuff
really great stuff spotting that plan is
what earns people their titles
well yeah uh spotting that plan from
afar i would argue is
is what makes wei yi such a good player
because
i think a lot of players would actually
sort of surprise themselves
in in this position if they actually get
it on the board it's sort of process of
elimination you're like well
have to like break this blockade somehow
and eventually might arrive at this plan
uh but okay let's do a quick review of
this game and then we'll move on
to a second game and that might be all
we have time for moving a little bit
slowly tonight
uh so we had the grunfeld and again the
idea of the grunfeld
to challenge the white's powerful center
on
these dark squares so we get c5 that's
why we see bishop g4
ready to trade off this bishop for the
knight queen a4 check is a little bit of
a nuance here preventing ideas of queen
a5
knight c6 rook c1 threatening d5 so we
see
takes takes in e6 now bishop b5
is fracturing black structure as well
and we arrived at
our key move of the opening which is h4
really instructive idea here by wei yi
covering all of the weaknesses in the
structure
with the pieces right using
this slightly weak slightly isolated
h-pawn
in order to help cover the weaknesses in
the camp
then king f1 king g2
further helping to cover the weaknesses
making use of the king
rather than trying to keep it on perhaps
the safest square
on e2 really good stuff and then from
here we saw the nice idea
of planting this rook on d6 with the
exchange sacrifice
uh and now black's only chance for
equality was to find some way to like
sort of immediately deal with this d6
pawn
and zhu zhongyu was unable to do that in
the game you see the king's side
pressure coming
and then from here we saw the the
shuffle fest
and wei yi eventually finding the
winning plan
with rooks off the board
bishop c7 a5 bishop b6 really
killer stuff here bishop d8 in black
resigns so questions on this game before
i move on
is wei yi the number three in china um
uh he's either number two or number
three he bounces back and forth with
yu yang yi i believe
bounces back and forth
jeff asks if i would have found that
idea at the board
i don't know because i've never had that
position on the board
it's possible it's possible you might
find the idea you never know
okay let us move along then
[Music]
yeah peter peterson says if you didn't
know who would play who played you would
say they were very bad players
allowing such bad structures but the key
is how
they handled the badge structures how
each player tried to cover their
weaknesses
and how wei yi did a better job and
because of that was able to win the game
now game number two let's move along
speaking
of you yang yi let's check out a game of
his and unfortunately our victim this
time
is still going to be shu zhongyu who who
just had a tough time against these two
leaders
uh in the tournament uh so let's take a
look we again have d4
this time we see d5 c4 e6
knight f3 and knight d7
so a little bit of a strange move over
to here by black uh committing to the
knight on d7 rather early
but this is actually something i think
these these top players are doing on
occasion i think i remember some sort of
grishak game
where he was playing in early knight d7
uh and yeah
i don't know it seems to be picking up
in popularity and let's check out why
uh knight c3 and we do still see knight
g to f6 now transposing to
some normalcy c takes d5 e takes d5
bishop f4 and then our key move of the
opening here
sort of our opening defining move is
going to be
knight b6 and this is the reason for the
early 97
by yu yang yi the idea was to plant this
knight on b6 and this is a rather
interesting idea
that i didn't fully understand until i
was doing some prep
for this class so why put this knight on
b6 what's going on
well at first glance it looks like black
is sort of
uh optimistically aiming for the c4
square sort of just hoping
that they'll be able to plant a knight
here and have some quick
queen side pressure maybe on the dark
squares like something like a bishop
coming out a queen
not a king coming up but maybe maybe a
queen coming out
something like this and at the surface
level this is what this idea
appears to be but then
looking at this game i it really does
become clear that the idea of knight b6
is sort of much much deeper
deeper than that uh the idea of knight
b6 as we'll see
is to actually lend further support to
the d5 pawn
and because of this extra support black
is going to have a lot more
options against white's main plan of the
minority attack so
this game we're talking about the knight
on b6 that's what we're talking about
okay white continues normally with the
move e3 all perfectly fine
we do see now bishop f5 and this is
another benefit
of perhaps having this knight here on b6
early on
now moves like queen b3 which tend to be
a response to an early bishop
development
are a lot less threatening with the
knight well placed to
defend uh and also the knight is is out
of the way of the bishop of course
uh we do see bishop d3 by white and we
get this trade of bishops
now bishop d6 offering a second trade
but
zhu zhongyu wants to keep this one on
the board plays bishop g5
and black simply retreats back to e7
uh happy to break the pin we see castles
and
castles and then white makes a pretty
interesting decision here
and chooses to capture the knight on f6
leaving black with this bishop and i
think the reason
for this idea was to make sure
white had sort of an extra piece that
could help
with the minority attack on uh on the
queen's side
the best this bishop can do is really
defend a square like c7 from d6
and and guard these squares on the queen
side
whereas the knight perhaps would have
been a more useful uh
attacking and even defending piece
jumping into a square like e4
perhaps looking to dominate a square
like c4 and
could just influence the queen side a
bit more i think that is the the idea
behind this trade namely no knight e4
and
less influence on the queen side for
black
but let's take a look at it here so
white continues uh quite naturally with
the move b4
just trying to go for this natural
minority attack on the queen's side
we also see black sort of playing in the
natural way against it as well
with a6 just looking to stop b5
because this pawn would capture and
black would get activity
down the a file and now we see knight
back to d2
we see bishop back to e7 attacking this
guy
rook f2b1 again white's plan is to open
things up on the queen slide as
you often do see in uh
in the exchange qgd and now c6
okay and now a4 by white and after
black's next move
g6 i want to stop so
the idea of this knight on b6 is yes
early on
black can bring this bishop out to f5
and things of that nature
but i think the the real point is is
really going to be shown now
so white has done everything right right
white has
brought pieces to the queen side put the
rooks in optimal position
to play the minority attack and now all
that's left is is to play the move b5
so what is stopping white from playing
b5 here chat
what is the point what is black's idea
against the move b5 see if you can
figure it out
what is black's idea here
umberto asks will these lessons help you
get to 2000 elo
that's the idea of the class that's the
idea at least
maybe it works maybe doesn't
so pippin chuck is close pippin chuck is
on the right
on the right track here on the right
track
on the right track
and yeah chess king seems to be the
first with the exact right idea here
so the point of this knight on b6 as i
said
is to yes support this pawn on d5
a little bit more than it otherwise
would be able to
right you know another common plan for
example is to bring this knight out to
g6 like this is something that that
happens quite often
sometimes you even see this knight jump
into a square like like g7 through some
manner like this or at least the e6
square
these are the more traditional plans
rather than leaving this knight on a
slightly awkward looking b6
but from b6 this knight is yes
very much able to control the d5 pawn
and more than that
controls yes c4 but even the a4 square
turns out to be relevant here
so uh hopefully a lot of you know that
in this
carl's badge structure as it's called
the main plan for white is this minority
attack
or at least one of the main plans is the
minority attack
pushing these this pawn minority forward
against the pawn majority
and so the power of this setup is that
black is just well prepared to deal with
the minority attack
so against b5 i think black's best play
is in fact going to be to take with the
c pawn which you might not expect
and after a takes b5 pushing forward
with a5
and i think it's actually black with a
slight edge in this position
the reason for that being our bishop is
now actually going to be useful
uh helping to support uh further a pawn
pushes
and aside from that yes our knight can
still jump in
to c4 but it's going to be rather
difficult
for uh for white to deal with this past
a pawn
in the coming end game uh and from b6
the knight is already useful
supporting this pawn on d5 really
this is just a good position for black
which is not supposed to happen
when you play a minority attack you're
supposed to get some sort of structural
advantage not not disadvantage
so there's not a v6 it's it's really
powerful stuff here really powerful
stuff
uh let's compare this idea if our knight
were
on a lesser square so let me play some
moves here
let's say white passes and for example
our knight were on g6 a perfectly
reasonable square
for the knight to be on now if we were
to try the same plan
c takes b5 a takes b5 a5
uh what would happen here what would
happen here what would white play
in this position
what would white play in this position
and yeah you guys have the right idea uh
maybe other moves are also good for
white but b6
is a really critical idea here for white
further taking space on the queen side
essentially isolating this pawn here on
a5
and granting the white pieces a few
extra squares to work with
so i think here it's actually white
who's on the better side of things after
the move b6
compared to our game where
white after g6 just simply should not go
for this idea
because the black forces are just well
prepared for it
i do want to mention though by the way
these ideas of c5 and a takes b5 and c5
are definitely worth keeping in mind as
well definitely worth keeping in mind
good stuff there
so for the moment though b5 not such a
great move for white so what should
white do instead
well in the game jeongyou was
unfortunately unable to come up
with the right ideas so i think here
white does have a pretty reasonable plan
that might not lead to an advantage
but at least is something constructive
for white to work towards right find a
constructive plan
for white here
okay so chess king has one idea of f3
and e4
and caesar martin has thrown out the
move a5
and so yeah i think this idea of a5 i
want to talk about first because i think
it is a really good idea
for white in this position so how do you
arrive
at the move a5 well for one it
is a little bit counter-intuitive to
make this pawn permanently backwards
and even further from that to cement
your pawns on dark squares
against a dark squared bishop but the
idea here is that white is actually
quite seriously playing against this
bishop
and how how so well for example let's
say
knight back to c8 now there are a number
of ways
that that white could continue the
simplest might be to play knight a4
let's say something like bishop f6 for
example knight b3
knight d6 even and maybe okay maybe
allowing knight b6 is a little bit
suboptimal but let's just say
like knight b to c5 for example now all
of a sudden
yes all of our pawns are in dark squares
but in this case it's a good thing when
we give up the darkest word bishop
we want to still have some dark squared
control so in this case
white is controlling those squares with
the pawns and it's going to have very
active pieces
now is white much better in this
position honestly
probably not but black is going to be a
little bit
under a little bit of pressure on the
queen side and won't really be given the
free reign to play on the king side
that we see in the game so i think a5
would have been a really useful idea
here
and just sort of play the the closed
position against the bishop
i do want to mention one more idea for
white though after a5 white can also
very seriously consider opening things
up in the center
with the move e4 not necessarily f3 e4
which might make
a little bit too many weaknesses against
this king but just
e4 with again the same idea
of planting these knights on the dark
squares on the
on the queen side and white would again
be doing
just fine here so instead though white
opted
to play rather slowly and
unfortunately here we're going to see
that it's actually black who's able to
make more
constructive moves on the king side and
in the center then
white so black just continues with rook
e8
activating the rook we see knight back
to e2
and again it does sort of feel like
white is moving in
the wrong direction here right this
knight would have loved to come invade
the queen slide after a move like a5
and is just retreating now bishop d6
again black just further activates the
pieces king g2
and now queen e7 and all of a sudden
it's it's white
uh kind of on the back foot again this
idea of b5
is going to be by c takes uh a takes and
now a5
and black is better so queen c3
instead defending the pawn and now
everybody's favorite plan
uh of course we see uh the h-pawn
storming up the board as you so often do
now white does still continue some
strange ideas here with knight back to
c1
potentially aiming for d3 in these
squares
but it's a bit too late uh now we see
the move
knight d7 and while this does seem a
little bit strange
because this knight on b6 has been
preventing white from playing
the uh the pawn break this entire time
now
uh black may potentially even have
different ideas
against the breaks so what happens if b5
here
well the answer is black can do sort of
any number of things
and be a bit better this idea is
actually still
a good one because b6 is simply not good
enough
we're going to go a4 neither of these
knights can really move to the queen
slide and this pawn is powerful
and if you think you're winning a pawn
there is bishop to b4
as a little tactic and
black wins in exchange okay
aside from that though there is another
idea here and
with the knight having vacated the b
file c5 would also potentially be
a good response as would a takes a takes
followed by c5 this would also be
perfectly fine
for black here uh but okay so knight
back to d7 because it's simply no longer
necessary to have it on b6
because white has really spent the past
few moves making all of his pieces worse
um that's that's the short of it then it
comes back out to d3
and now we see black preparing to attack
on the king's side
having locked things down on the queen's
side black now advances plans on the
king's side as you should do
in the qgd uh rook over to e1 now
but this is just just the wrong plan now
for for white now we see
h4 and white goes for this f3 e4 plane
that's uh chess king in the chat
mentioned but with the pawn already on
h4
it's far too slow and white has far too
many weaknesses
we see h takes g3 and white sort of goes
a little bit crazy here
should have played h just recapturing
the pawn with h takes g3
and dealt with the weaknesses around the
king white is going to be worse but at
least not totally lost yet
instead white tried this idea of h3
uh with a pawn shield on g3 but this is
bad
for for obvious reasons right you're
never really able to capture this
g3 pawn and your king isn't exactly safe
with this as a pawn shield uh the game
does continue though with knight h5
aiming to attack some of these weak dark
squares now that the g3 pawn is dead
uh white breaks through with e4 in the
center
but it's it's just not meant to be we
see bishop f4
invading on these newly weak and dark
squares
if you thought you were going to try
e takes d5 you thought wrong here
because
black to move and win is pretty nice
here you can just play move like queen
g5 and be better
but queenie two check is actually also
also winning
no idea if you actually saw this or not
but
uh this is rather nice rather nice
for uh for black here just just check
mating the king oh sorry not rook d8 but
rookie 8 i missed
just check mating the k right just just
getting checkmated here
um so e takes d5 not playable bishop f4
the knight just moves out to b3 but now
queen g5
and uh i think things are tough things
are tough rookie two
we just double rooks on the e file and
again white is just never recovering
um ricky one rookie eight queen back to
b2
now queen up to h4 knight c5
and knight back to f6 which is
potentially a little bit wrong
but perfectly fine still just piling up
the pressure here
now we do see knight takes f4 queen
takes f4
e5 knight back to h5 queen d2
and here queen d2 surprisingly
lays a little bit of a trap there's a
little bit of a trap
trap here a little trap poo so uh
actually sort of falls for the trap here
and gives white an opportunity to come
back into the game
uh the best move would have been
something like b6 something like queen
f5 even f6 is
is perfectly fine just highlighting the
fact that these pawns are going to fall
in the center
but instead we see queen h4 and now
white to move
into stunning astonishingly get back
into this game
get back in this game uh go ahead and
pause the video if you want to figure it
out we are running short on time so i'm
just going to show it now
but wait to move get back in the game
the answer of course
is rookie 4. nobody saw it coming
nobody saw it coming rook e4 and the
point now
is that your queen doesn't have anywhere
to go
nowhere to go for the queen nowhere to
go it's so so sad
but yu yangi finds the counter punch to
stay back in the game
which is rook takes e5 sacrificing the
rook back giving the queen a flight
square
but after d takes e5 we do see rook d8
and here white does sort of
start to slip again uh the best move to
stay in the game was actually
somehow knight d7 and this is this is
sort of just
engine stuff at this point where like
okay maybe you see that knight d7 is a
good move but queen e3 is perfectly
natural
but now after queen e7 black is able to
regroup
keep this pawn here on g3 and this pawn
is going to give
all the advantage e6 is a good idea
queen f6 and then white should have
tried e takes f7
and just played for activity but instead
e7
is actually going to be the losing move
here after queen b2 check
when white has no good way to save the
king and this powerful pawn on g3
does finally tell the tail we get queen
back to e2
really the only move now queen takes e2
rick takes c2
uh we'll start queen takes e2 check and
uh
and white had to resign the game would
have continued with rick take c2 when
after knight f4 check
there is rather surprisingly no way
to uh to not lose this rook with check
or allow black to uh to save the rook
for example
king f1 means rook d one check rick g
one now g2 check king f2 rookie one
stop spike from queening and then black
is able to queen
or king takes g3 knight takes e2 check
and then black will save the rook
so sort of a wild game there at the end
that i sort of blew by
the main point i wanted to talk about
with this game is this idea
of the knight on b6 hopefully this is an
idea that is useful to you
in your games uh with the black side of
the qgd
and hopefully you're a little bit more
aware now of how to deal with it
if you're playing with the white side a
few tips
number one i'm still not sold on this
bishop takes f6 idea
maybe it's a good positional idea but if
you do go for something like bishop
takes f6 i think definitely
this plan of a5 and using the knights to
invade these dark squares
is sort of the best that white can do it
may not lead to a distinct advantage
but it is a constructive good plan that
is going to put some pressure on black
in the meantime though this plan of just
sort of restructuring the pieces
if you do nothing for a while black has
useful things to do and those useful
things are to attack you on the king's
side
and that's never fun so that's where
things went wrong for zhu zhongyu in
this game
and that's how yu yangi managed to
defeat his opponent
so questions on this game before we call
it a night here
on the road to 2000.
any final questions for me final
questions
right no questions everybody understands
perfectly
i assume that's what it means uh can
someone starting chess as an adult
so always the chat just has general
questions rather than questions about
the lecture but that's that's
fine yeah merry christmas by the way
everyone uh this will be my last lecture
uh before uh for the holiday here
but oh nope
continuing on okay uh incus state has
asked can someone starting chess as an
adult and get to 2000
and the answer is yes there are very few
things that you can't achieve as an
adult starting chess
some people argue it's like pretty
difficult maybe impossible to get to
like the the gm level
but 2000 is very very achievable i think
national master is very achievable
i think feed a master is very achievable
i think even
even a little bit higher than that may
also be perfectly achievable
uh you know the argument that kids
are able to reach these big heights
because they learn it while their brain
is more malleable
is one that people make i think the main
reason why
adults can't get as good as at chess as
quickly as kids
is because they just don't have time
that's the huge limiting factor they
just don't have time to stick with it
they don't have time to study they you
know
work they have a life things like that
things that kids don't have
and that's the main limiting factor
there so if you have the time
i think you can do very very great
things in the world of chess
anyways with that let's call tonight
here if you are watching live please
head on over to the end game class which
will be
immediately following this one here on
the channel
if you've had enough of chess for
tonight or if you're watching the
replay version thank you very much for
watching as always my name is caleb
denby
and i will see you next time
you